there was a story in the wall street
journal that said how to know that
inflation is here to stay
and they said you know the fed is saying
it's temporary you know we have we have
a sudden surge of demand because the
restrictions are being lifted however
what they notice is really interesting
they said american families are flush
with cash
yeah they've been getting because of all
the stimulus they've just been giving
people money but there's nothing to buy
so what happens
now some people couldn't pay their rent
people in big cities were having
problems
but what happens to the average family
where they're being given the stimulus
and they're just putting in their
account they're not doing anything with
it
we see this all the time in the super
chats people are like hey here's a super
chat from my stimi
it's like a lot of people weren't
sweating that much they got this money
some people said they bought doge with
it some people were saying you know that
they're buying bitcoin or whatever but
so now we're hearing that a lot of
people have a savings
they have cash that means they don't
need jobs
yep so mcdonald's and these other fast
food restaurants are offering 500
000 sign-on bonuses no one needs the
money
or i shouldn't say no one but a lot of
people don't so they don't take the job
not only that you can't buy the things
you want i i hear every day so
for my friends like man i've been trying
to buy a ps5 i can't get one
if the ps5 doesn't exist why would
someone
don't get a job to to buy one if you
can't buy it you can't buy it
so what do they really want right now so
that means a lot of people who normally
would be like hey i need to get a job
because i really want to get the new
playstation are going to be like i don't
need to
yeah i can live in a van and just sit
here then you have people who have tons
of money in their savings saying
as soon as the ps5 comes out i can go
buy it why get a job i've got money
in the bank the only problem is if you
don't work to make stuff
there's no stuff to buy exactly so this
seems like
either accidentally maybe it's on
purpose the mass printing of money which
binding's not gonna do another six
trillion dollars
yeah hyperinflation is here to stay but
it's worse than that
supply won't come back if no one needs
to work and if no one needs to work then
nothing gets made and if i think it's
made no one buys anything
this to me sounds like it is the great
reset i think the left if we let them go
unchecked that's what they want is they
want total control because right now
with cova they're able to accelerate the
program they've been working on for
years they kill off all the industry
jobs through over-regulation
the right establishment does it too at
the altar of the free market
and then uh the culture war coming in
and saying that everybody must go to
college and you don't really
want to have a family you don't really
need to uh get married have kids and all
that type of stuff you can't have kids
right now i mean climate change
i'm a gif we might all die it's
irresponsible right yeah
so they they want to be able to control
people government becomes family
government becomes god
and then now we have the stimulus coming
in kovid just let them fully accelerate
i think the economic part because then
they got the they had been talking about
ubi for a long time and people were like
we're not going to do ubi
and they kept pushing it and then it's
like whoa guys global pandemic no one
can work let's just get them all hooked
on free cash and now it's total control
but it's not ubi it's iub it's our year
it's indefinite unemployment benefits
okay yeah so it's even worse yeah but it
is interesting
over the past year and now we're we're
halfway into this year
yeah people haven't been able to buy all
the things they wanted
there's been shortages of everything and
they're trying to trying to condition
people that this is the new norm that
hey you're just going to go long periods
where like you can't work but we got you
but you're not really going to be able
to work hard to get the things that you
want because that's not obtainable
anymore
you know i will say first and foremost i
think it's good if people aren't being
driven by material possessions for their
self-worth
i think the idea that uh if people learn
how to roll up their sleeves and go chop
some wood to get their homes instead of
digging coal and burn itself i like that
idea yeah but this is a
not a conservative problem i think
conservatives for the most part know how
to chop lumber
and take care of themselves this is a
big city liberal problem they're the
ones who are going to be left high and
tried this is i'll tell you what i find
fascinating all this is happening
whether it's just a natural flow of the
system or it's intentional
before kovet there was this big push on
youtube for van life
have you seen this stuff yeah so is it a
coincidence that
youtube is promoting all these van life
videos people go on youtube and they say
hey
ditch your homes go live in a van quit
your job
yeah it's like okay so you can't own a
bunch of stuff right you won't own a
bunch of stuff you'll live in a van
you'll take up less space and humans
will spread out i'm like
i like the idea of van life i personally
love the idea of
being self-sufficient and personally
responsible yeah and encouraging these
people in cities to
do so so i'm i have no problem with but
i do find it very
interesting that this narrative emerges
then we get the whole lockdown thing
i think when it comes to covid the
democrats immediately said don't let a
good crisis go to waste oh absolutely
and and and so i'll clarify too i'm not
saying you know
what i'm saying specifically is covid
was exploited
by progressives and leftists for their
climate change agenda
what i mean by that is very early on
they weren't on board
with with this idea of like you know
locking down they're knocking down yeah
fauci was saying no going to cruise no
big deal then all of a sudden they
flipped like wait a minute
actually we should shut things down we
should
you know pause everything we should stop
travel yeah they said trump was wrong
for banning travel
actually yeah i think they realized like
wait a minute this is very good
politically for what we've been trying
to do
then all of a sudden a 15 day to stop
the spread turned into
you're still here my state were still
there yeah because uh and
and and uh not now vaccine passports i
think
we saw in the new york times the planet
is finally healing because of the
lockdowns
they very much were like can we just
keep this thing going as long as
possible right
because it serves our agenda i think
they saw that a lot of the things that
the media and even people on the right
said that trump was crazy for preaching
on the campaign trail when he said we
can bring back american manufacturing
you know the all the economists said no
those jobs are gone and dead and there's
no way that working class wages can rise
like that
that had been the rule of economics for
years but trump between 2017 and right
before covet came like working-class
wages were rising
and the economy was doing really really
well and so they were about a year out
from the presidential election and so
like you said
don't let a good crisis go to waste like
let's let's accelerate this and you can
do that when you have the media pretty
much 100 percent on your side
yeah cnn particularly yeah right the
cuomo brothers
you know it's remarkable too because
people can make fun of their low ratings
all day and night but they get hundreds
of millions of views on youtube
youtube puts them on the front page
right you search for this news
cnn comes up absolutely i can do you
know a two-hour interview with you
and then cnn can produce a one-minute
clip and if you search youtube what are
you gonna get you're gonna get the cnn
one minute clip they were posting death
number cover death numbers
uh project veritas right yeah really
blew the lid off of that it's just
insidious panic for views basically yeah
and then trump sent out the uss comfort
out there and they refused to use it
while
you know cuomo and de blasio are still
getting all people back in
old folks homes you mentioned that
things were going really well under
trump economically
it wasn't just wages a lot of the things
the progressives have had been demanding
were naturally occurring like a four-day
work week several large businesses
announced that they were doing for
four-day work weeks because they were
doing so well yeah reduced work hours a
lot of businesses announced this
paid vacations benefits all of a sudden
we started seeing businesses be like
we're gonna pay more we're gonna do
vacations the economy is doing so well
yeah so it's different from an
artificial inflated wage increase right
like
the government mandates it or it's
required because of mass spending
yeah this was legitimate the economy was
kicking up
people were having vacations people were
doing well i remember when we were
starting the show i went to a furniture
place and i was like we got to buy
furniture for the show and the lady
there was like 2019 was the best year of
my life
because this was january of 2020 like
yeah december january
we had a guy come out doing landscaping
and he was like last year was the best
year i ever had
so this was genuinely people doing
commerce with each other but that's the
opposite of what a lot of these
democrats wanted exactly they didn't
want everyone buying and building more
right they want a retraction yep they
want people living in vans under trump
that's right people were building
castles for themselves figuratively like
they're improving their homes they were
growing their families things were
better than ever
those people are harder to control you
you want the i'm the guy that gives you
your income
i tell you what little pods you can live
in like you can't go have any of the
resources i'll give you the resources
that's where
the left has just become the
authoritarian the authoritarians
i'll tell you what's funny we have we
have the meme you know i will not eat
the bugs i will not live in the pod
yeah i think it's funny because i've
said on the show numerous times i don't
mind eating bugs if i if i have to
because i think if you're if you're
going to be gritty hardcore survivalist
and want to be responsible you'll do
what you got to do to survive and i
don't mind living in a pod
if it's like i'm in the forest i've got
my own little hut that i've built and
i'm responsible for myself i'm fine with
that sure
the funny thing is the the city dwelling
liberal types have been living in the
pot already
yeah like new york's been famous for
their cubicle
apartments where it's like the kitchen
and the the bathroom like
there's a toilet in your kitchen yeah
yeah everything's crammed together so
people in the cities have already been
living in the pods right now the new
stores are coming out saying hey go eat
the cicadas go go eat the bugs yeah yeah
that's the city people you live in the
country we've got chickens outside right
exactly
we have we have farms everywhere out
here you drive up you walk in you got
fresh meat
yep you live in the city you might gotta
eat the bugs yup but so i'm like you
know
if they want to do their thing the only
issue is they want everyone to do the
same thing
they want they want rules that are based
off of a city perspective that will
affect literally everybody
so then you live in the middle of
nowhere and you've got you know a cow
and you want to you know produce some
beef and then you get federal regulators
saying you can't we're putting a hold
so we we recently went to farms and they
were told like
there's a shortage because the usda or
whatever regulatory agency was saying we
weren't allowed to
you know serve up the beef or something
yeah they were like restricting the
dates because of covid
then you get the gun laws they want to
make people who live in the middle of
nowhere who aren't
the problem right live by the rules of
the people in the city who are the
problem
full control everything they're doing is
is just geared towards that full control
because people
in the country that are self-sufficient
or that have their hands on a key lever
of the economy
production like they're independent they
they as they say
cling to their gods and their guns and
they build families and they're kind of
hard to go screw with as opposed to the
the guys that live in the pods in the
city that are waiting to work on the gig
economy or
they're begging for the next tech job
you know i i think it's funny too it's
like
it's interesting like conservatives are
defending liberals in a sense
because they're like we shouldn't have
to do these things and i'm like wait
guys guys guys like
if you live in the country and you
already know how to source your own food
how to start your own fires
your profession with weapons i
understand not the regulation pushing
back
but if they want to live in the city and
live in pods and eat bugs hey go for it
just let them see the thing yeah yeah
yeah they're the ones
who are gonna have to do it the cities
are the ones who are gonna have to
dramatically change
right you know is it like a
miscalculation by these city dwellers
uh out of ignorance that they're that
they're trying to legislate
city doctrine for everyone across the
country or is it
do you think it's more malicious i think
at the top levels it's more malicious
because you you do
i think the the top of the left wing
they really want that full authoritarian
control
i think they've done a good job of kind
of brainwashing
lower information people and they've
done that by infiltrating the media and
the education system
and most people that are going to live
in a city they've been told that hey to
make it in the big city
you need to have a college degree in
something you know and so i think the
universities that just became an
indoctrination factory a long time ago
where they've been sold this whole
religion of like hey whoever's in charge
is who you listen to was the professor
in school
and now it's the government as long as
we get our our team in government
that's exactly who you listen to and if
the other team gets in the mean orange
man
like no matter what he says like that's
got to be wrong and it's not just wrong
he's a nazi and so whatever you
whatever you need to do to take that
away is the right thing and you're
you're morally superior
i i think if i was gonna make a
prediction either there's gonna be a
great upheaval a very serious
conflict or within two three years
everyone's going to be living in pods
and bugs
no joke i think you know people out in
the country will still have their farm
animals probably be
less likely to be eating bugs but the
way things are going
the way the the political uh agenda is
going i
that that's where we're headed i think
this is a testing period right now i
mean i think we're on the precipice of
either
the country drastically changing and we
becoming way more authoritarian where we
have to listen to whoever is in
washington dc
and they they have very control of
intimate aspects of our lives
or i think we're going to see a huge
pushback i'm i'm optim
cautiously optimistic i should say that
in 22 there's going to be
a bunch of america first candidates go
and take the house and the senate back
and then we're going to have two years
of
of hard legislative fights hard culture
war fights media fights
but i do believe then we're going to be
able to get enough momentum to take the
country back in 2024.
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time